[Laughter]
that's my question because when I was
online on Twitter on social media I'm
seeing them getting Brave
these people were getting Brave how come
today it was like pin drop silence
how come today when it's not one person
or two people walking the street yeah
when it's one or two Muslims look in the
street when it's a vulnerable adult when
it's someone running home yeah how comes
now yeah how comes you're not here now
I'll tell you why tell you why because
your feelings when they're near us
hold on brother let me tell you why it
is yeah because deep down yeah they know
we got the truth
actually no two respect yeah
if they're doing The Reincarnation yeah
what a humiliation and pathetic thing
for them to be reincarnated into some
prophetic weak cowardly people like that
I'd rather be an animal I'd rather be
reincarnated as a Greek grasshopper
brother
that's the truth so how comes now in
Leicester
coming out yeah and you're trying to act
like gangsters you're trying to act like
gangsters
come on man you're not about that life
don't ever I'm saying this I'm saying
this directly to order so-called
hindutva Wannabe Gangsters Don't ever
come out like that again do you
understand are they gonna come out like
that again
because if they do come out are we gonna
be here yes or no
please